I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense
when I was I had zero interest of
opening the textbook zero I don't know
timid aided by it or I just wasn't
interested in it but I didn't have it I
don't think you're alone I think that a
lot of people don't I didn't look I was
good in school I didn't study
I always got like a 3.5 or above and
just like but I didn't ever study and I
didn't really love it and in fact I
asked my social studies teacher in fifth
grade what the point of the class was
because I just didn't get it
but now I want to learn I think the I
think that school is all messed up I
think that when we go at the wrong age
but anyway so you're not interested in
opening a book I agree school and went
to work in a restaurant as a cook and I
started with my hands and then I
actually got interested in light right
there that's how life did you find that
you say life that sounds pretty pretty
transformative so well there's something
to be said for being inspired and
enjoying life and being positive it's
opened my eyes up to the world I mean
the one thing that I'll never forget
there's a guy who hands me a check to my
house with my culinary mm-hmm and he
said to me I'm doing this because I want
to I was i worth to him because I'm
doing this by watching you don't all be
anything I just want you to remember
something if you become successful as a
cook you can take this anywhere in the
world
playa and when he said it to me it
didn't really register but now I know
that anywhere in the world I go to I can
go anywhere I can go to Italy and go to
Thailand I go to Russia it doesn't
matter I can walk into a kitchen not
speak your language and then hmm
Wow she's amazing it's kind of like math
you can do it anywhere math is math
cooking is cooking me neither me neither
like last year I did something that I
tell me because I've never been there so
when I go I need to know all the dates
agree I can get Italian wine somewhere
but let's face it it's not Italy I took
last year right around this time last
year I was on the Amalfi Coast rent and
you know because you know it's right on
the Mediterranean and it's where like
Capri is humble brag I love it
no I want you to keep going yeah I
[Music]
called my office and I said ladies
cancel everything on my schedule for the
entire month of September oh my god and
that's May time you could do like
schedule I was like if it's not
important we need to I said I need to do
this to me
Wow was this last year it was this 2018
yeah okay and I took my cat nacho nut
down went the wrong six weeks just
completely by myself and I had I had no
plans except that was gonna live in a
row and I signed up for Italian classes
three and a half hours every day with a
bunch of people who whoa and and I went
and you know went to eat lunch and
dinner every day and I walk into the
restaurant and I will talk to the chefs
and then they would invite me to come
their restaurants and it was an amazing
experience because my business I have to
say that I really feel like the food
business the restaurant business is the
most generous business period we are
competitive we are we have amazing
camaraderie mm-hmm
so like when when another chef comes
into my restaurant he's given like the
red carpet experience like I feel this
way about the wine business I make one
and if you're the same you're
competitive but it's like all for one I
think very much and I don't speak
Italian I can get by Italy mm-hmm but it
didn't matter because when we were all
cooking Seattle I was in their kitchens
we spoke the same language
[Music]